[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه ستون
برنامجن اخباري خاص ومتنوع وبقاع سريع
ومختلف جدا نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبعمق
وبين العجل والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم
والصوره الكامله البدايه من العناوين
حرب بارده التجسس الكلاسيكي لا يزال حاضرا
الصين الخصم الاكثر خطوره على امريكا
وانا نفسه عقليه الحرب البارده تنتقل ايضا
لبحر الصين الجنوبي وشبه الجزيره الكوريه
هل نحن امام نيتو اسيوي
وفي ملفات الساعه ستون فوضى فبراير في
الافق دقت ساعه الحظر على المشتقات
النفطيه الروسيه بعد تحديد سقف اسعار
صادرات موسكو
الخلافات في السياسه ليست ابديه ملامحه
صفقات سياسيه بين تركيا والنظام السوري هل
يعرقلها الكيماوي
[موسيقى]
اذا اراد الروس الحصول على رمالنا من شاطئ
مميز ستدخل غواصه في الليل يتسلل طاقمها
يحصل على رمال يحمله على الغواصه ويغادر
لكن اذا ارادت الصين نفس الامر سيكون
لديها 500 شخص في نزهات حول الشاطئ يلتقط
كل منهم الرمال في علب صغيره ثم يغادرون
هكذا يفرق العميل السابق لمكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه نيكولاس افتميادوس الاسلوب
الصيني عن الروسي وورد ذلك في كتابه
عمليات الاستخبارات الصينيه ولهذا السبب
قد تكون الصين الخصم الوحيد الاكثر فاعليه
وخطوره على الولايات المتحده ولا دليل على
ذلك اكثر من المنطاد الذي يجوب سماء
الولايات المتحده والذي تقول الصين انها
فقدت السيطره عليه يدور صغيرا لنا في
الصور والمقاطع المصوره لكنه بحجم ثلاث
حافلات
اين هو المنطاد الان المتوقع ان يصل اليوم
للساحل الشرقي ثم ينتقل للبحر في الجنوب
الشرقي بالقربي من لكنه اختفى من موقع
التتبع فلايت ريدر اربعه وعشرين اليوم زاد
الطينه بالله من تجسس اخر صيني ايضا يحلق
فوق امريكا اللاتينيه بحسب البلتاجون ولم
يتم تحديد موقعه بدقه حتى الان لكن مسؤولا
امريكيا ما اكد لسينان ان المنطاد الثاني
يتوجه نحو الولايات المتحده ايضا الاجواء
في واشنطن متوتره جدا فلدا الولايات
المتحده تاريخا من التجسس مع الصين
وسنفصله لكم بعد قليل لكن هذه الاجواء
جعلت الخارجيه الصينيه تتهم السياسيين
ووسائل الاعلام الامريكيه استغلال الوضع
للتشويه شمعه سمعه الصين فهي تصر على
مدنيه المنطاد الذي دخل دون قصد اجواء
الولايات المتحده الامر كان مفاج نعم لكن
بالنسبه للدوله رقم واحد في العالم كانت
تعلم قبلها اطلع الرئيس جو بايدن يوم
الثلاثاء اي قبل الحادثه بيومين على ان
هناك بالون مراقبه صيني يشتبه به يحوم فوق
الولايات المتحده لكن المفارقه هناك
مدنيون هم من ابلغوا عن المنطاد بعدما
قاموا بتصويره
[موسيقى]
عموما ليست المره الاولى التي يرصد فيها
من تاظم صيني في اجواء الولايات المتحده
وذلك بحسب مسؤولين امريكيين لكن يبدو ان
هذا البالون او المنطاد باقن لفتره اطول
من المعتاد بحسب ما نقلت رويترز المنطاد
عاده ما يحمل كاميرا للمراقبه والاستطلاع
الجويه قد يحتوي ايضا على معدات كارادار
وفقا لصحيفه الجارديان وفي حاله هذا
المنطاد يرجح خبراء انه مزود بلواقب ترصد
الاتصالات العسكريه الامريكيه واشارات
اخرى استخباراتيه اقله لاغراض معرفه
التجاوب الامريكي مع خطر اختراق من طاب
للاجواء ربما يفسر ذلك بقاء المنطاد فتره
اطول مع استغلال تحسس واشنطن خطوره اسقاطه
السؤال المهم هل تقصدت بكين التجسس على
الولايات المتحده لغرض معين هل تستهدف
بالفعل منطقه او منشاه حساسه بعينها
المنطاد حلقه فوق جزر
في الاسكا وعبر كندا قبل ان يظهر فوق
مدينه بيلينكس في مونتانا ومونتانا هي
موطنه لواحد من ثلاثه اماكن فقدت في
الولايات المتحده تخزن فيها الصواريخ
النوويه في قاعده
الجويه
هدف ضخم لا شك ان كان المنطاد تجسسا كما
تقول واشنطن فلماذا اذا هذه الطريقه
الكلاسيكيه في التجسس كلاسيكيه بمعنى انها
تعود الى عام
1794 خلال معركه افلاورس في حرب التحالف
الاول وحتى ان الولايات المتحده استهلكت
استخدامها خلال الحرب البارده تطورت
التكنولوجيا منذ عقود لتحل الاقمار
الصناعيه المناطيل صور من الفضاء ادق واقل
خطوره فهل هناك ضروره للمنطاد اضافه الى
جميع الوسائل الحديثه للتجسس وهواوي
احداها بحسب اتهامات الولايات المتحده
للصين فان الاجابه في الحموله المنطاد يزن
اقل ويمكن ان يكون اصغر وارخص واسهل في
الاطلاق من الاقمار الصناعيه اذا تعددت
الطرق والحقيقه واحده الصين تغزو الولايات
المتحده على طريقتها خيالها تجاوز الحدود
في تجنيد ادواتها لاختراق امريكا وقبل
ازمه المنطاد او المعلن عن على الاقل قبل
هذه الواقعه كشفت الولايات المتحده عن
استثمارات زراعيه صينيه قرب منشات عسكريه
امريكيه استثمارات كانت سريه في البدايه
قبل ان يزاح الستار عن تفاصيلها
مثلا منذ اكثر من ثلاث سنوات امتلكت شركات
الصينيه اراضنا بمساحه شاسعه وتحديدا
بمساحه تقدر ب 777 كيلومترا مربعا واثقه
تقريرا لقناه فوكس نيوز صدر في يوليو من
العام الماضي التقرير حينها دقه ناقوس
الخطر استنادا الى ان هذه الاراضي تقع في
اغلبها قرب منشات عسكريه والشركات مرتبطه
بالحكومه الصينيه مساحه الاراضي التي
تمتلكها شركات صينيه زادت منذ هذه الفتره
وعندما نتحدث عن الهدف فهو طبعا لاغراض
التجسس كما يخشى مسؤولون امريكيون ويحضرون
دوما
اذا مشاهدينا وصلت الرساله ولنبدا فك
الشفاء في عالم التجسس لا باس ان نطلق
العنان قليلا لجيمس لكن لنعد الى العهد
القديم ونرى كيف تفنن العملاء السوريون في
اساليب التجسس الرسائل المشفره حشره
اليعسوب التي استخدمتها الاستخبارات
الامريكيه كجهاز للتنصت وايضا جذع الشجره
ازرار الخميس وحتى كعب الحذاء هذا صنعته
الاستخبارات السوفيتيه لمراقبه
الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين ولا ننسى القطه
المتجسسه بعد الحرب البارده زرعت واشنطن
في اذنيها ميكروفون للتجسس على السفاره
السوفييتيه في امريكا انذاك تطورت الوسائل
من الحشره وحتى الوصول الى هذه الحمامه
وتبدو مثل الطيور الحقيقيه بل وتتطابق
حركتها مع الحقيقيه بنسبه 90% صوتها
الخافت للغايه يصعب اكتشافها من قبل
الانسان والرادارات تحاكي الحمامه ايضا
المسيرات في حركه الخفقان لاجنحه الطائر
للتحليق والهبوط والانعطاف في الهواء حمام
الصينيه بالمناسبه
وصلنا الى التجسس السيبراني وهو الاحدث
الان اقمار التجسس غزت الفضاء البحر
والسماء ولا شك هواتفنا المقاله لكن ان
يكون التجسس عبر حديقه فهذا غير مالوف نعم
مشاهدينا انها الصين تجاوزت انشطتها
الحدود حديقه صينيه مزخرفه في قلب الحديقه
الوطنيه في واشنطن الامر يبدو طبيعيا
كمشروع تجاري بل وشجع السلطات الامريكيه
لجذب مزيدا من السياحه للعاصمه ليكتشف
لاحقا ان الحقيقه الحديقه هذه ستمتلئ
بتماثيل وهياكل وابراج ترتفع 70 قدما ستضع
بشكل استراتيجي في واحده من اعلى النقاط
في واشنطن وعلى بعد مليلين فقط من مبنى
الكابيتال تذكرت واشنطن حينها ابراجه
هواوي التجسسيه فقتلت مشروع الحديقه في
مهده
التكنولوجيا الصينيه سيما وان الجميع يعلم
انها تهدف للاساءه لامريكا
السنتر دعى ايضا لحظر جميع الشركات
الصينيه مثل تيك توك ودي جي جي اي وايضا
على راسها طبعا هواوي الان وبينما المنطاد
لا يزال يحلق في الاجواء الامريكيه خارج
عن السيطره اشتدت لهجه التصريحات
الامريكيه وتحديدا من الجمهوريين الذين
ينتقدون باستمرار لينا بايدن مع الصين
طبعا على عكس ترامب السنه في لجنه القوات
المسلحه
وصف تعامل الفانتاجون مع الحادثه بالفشل
في التعامل مع اختراق السياده الامريكيه
بينما وصف رئيس مجلس النواب الجمهوري كاظم
ماكارتي ما فعلته الصين بالواقع والمزعزع
للاستقرار وطلب من بايدن عدم التزام الصمت
وبالمناسبه حذر مكارسي الصين قبل ايام من
انها لم تستطيع منعه اذا اراد زياره
تايوان
اذا للمزيد ولمتابعه هذا الملف ينضم الينا
من واشنطن مدير برنامج التحليل السياسي
العسكري في معهد هاتسن اذا تجسس او منطاد
مدني الان هو خارج عن السيطره ماذا يعني
ذلك في حسابات الامن القومي لامريكا
المنطاد بحد ذاته
لا يشكل تهديدا اساسيا والا لكانوا قاموا
باسقاطه لكن رمزيه الامر
تنطوي على نواحن سيئه
اذ ان وزير الخارجيه كان سوف يجتمع مع
نظيره الصيني
وندرك وجود هذه
المناطيد التي
قد تكون على مقربه من مواقع نوويه وهناك
منطاد اخر يتم الحديث عنه الامر الذي قد
حدا بوزير الخارجيه لتاجيل زيارته لكن من
خلال المعلومات التي تم جمعها فانهم لم
يستطيعوا الحصول على اكثر من تلك
المعلومات التي ينال عليها من خلال
الاقمار الصناعيه المستخدمه في السابق نعم
سيد قلت انه لو كان المنطاد يشكل خطرا
لكان تم اسقاطه منذ مده ولكن بالامس
المتحدث باسم تحدث عن الخطر الذي قد ينجم
عن اسقاط هذا المنطاد لو تحدثنا اكثر عن
هذا الخطر
لقد قاموا باجراء تحليل يعتمد على المزايا
والمساوئ بمقدورهم اسقاطي هذا المنطاد
وبهذه الطريقه سوف يتم تبديل اي معلومات
يمكن للصينيين جمعها من هذا المنطاد لكنهم
قرروا ان مزايا هذا الاجراء قد تكون قليله
من حيث الحصول على المعلومات المطلوبه لكن
المخاطر او التكلفه لا تزال غير معروفه
فاذا ما تم اسقاط المنطاد
وتهاوى وسقط مثلا على مزرعه او حقل لا ضير
في ذلك لكن لو وقع او هبط على مدرسه فسوف
يكون هناك نتائج سيئه على الاطفال لذا
قرروا بعدم المضي ومن الحصول على مخاطر
اسقاط المنطاد على منطقه ماهوله في
الولايات المتحده
السيد ريتشارد لو توقفنا عند تصريح الرئيس
الامريكي قبل ق سنتعامل مع من تااد التجسس
الصيني بهذه الحاله ما هي خيارات التعامل
مع هذا المنطاد
لعله قد اتخذ القرار الاكثر اهميه بعدم
اسقاطه ولكنه قرر
ان لا يبعث
بوزير الخارجيه للاجتماعي مع نظيره الصيني
وهذا قد يصعب الامر في التواصل مع اصيل
يتوقف الامر على مكان توجهه هذا المنطاد
وهذا ما كان بمقدور الولايات المتحده
استرجاعه واختباره لكن لا نعلم ما الذي قد
يحدث
هناك من يقوم الان بالتقاط صور من اجل
اجراء عمليه تحليل واسعه عليه نعم اشكرك
جزيل الشكر كنت معنا من واشنطن مدير
برنامج التحليل السياسي العسكري في معهد
مشاهدينا نبقى مع الصين والولايات المتحده
ماذا ان قامت الحد المحاكاه في الساعه بعد
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
الحياه عذاب وقت ما تقدر تاخذ نفس عميق
يزيل احتقان الانف ست مرات اسرع من الحبوب
ويساعدك على التنفس بشكل افضل لغايه 12
ساعه خذ نفس عميق مع
هذه البلده الاستراتيجيه التي سيطرت عليها
القوات الروسيه منذ اليوم الاول التي تم
قصفها هنا في هذا المكان
المواد التوثيق هذه اللحظات هذا المبنى
الذي قصف
ما زالت الاشتباكات مستمره هذه قنبله
يدويه لم تنفجر بعدها نحن الان في مدينه
بريديانسكا الواقعه خارج حدود المناطق
الانفصاليه القديمه
نحن اول محطه نصل الى هذا المكان عندنا
هنا في دانيتك اليوم
حقيقه الامر بالفعل هنالك مقبره جماعيه
ايضا على هذه الممرات
هذه الجوله الحصريه التي تمكنا من الحصول
عليها ودخول بلده بوتشا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد العام الماضي حين اعلن
حلف الناتو عن استراتيجيته ذكر ذكر الصين
لاول مره واعتبرها تشكل وتحديا لمصالح دول
الحلف وامنها تحول استراتيجيا غير مسبوق
في العلاقات بين الطرفين واليوم ومن على
تخوم الصين يوضح الامين العام للناتو
وربه فيها فكره ان الصين لا تهم حلف
الشمال الاطلسي فكره غير عمليه الناتو
يوثقوا تعاونه مع شركائه في منطقه
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ لكن لماذا
لمواجهه خطر الصين وحليفتها كوريا
الشماليه فكانت اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
قبله
فهل هذه ملامح نيتو شرق اسيوي اخذ بالتشكل
هناك منطقه هذا الناقوس من قبل وتحديدا في
اغسطس الماضي زعيم كوريا الشماليه والرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
في هذا الخطاب اتهم الغرب بتاجيجه
نزاعاتنا في مناطق اخرى حول العالم شبه ما
يحدث في اوكرانيا بما يحدث في تايوان وكان
يتحدث عن سياره ناسيك وصفها بالاستفزاز
المخطط بدقه ومن الى حيث موقف موحد
لواشنطن وحلف النيتو يؤكد توقعات موسكو
وكوريا الشماليه يبحثان مظله ردع نووي
تشمل كوريا الجنوبيه ولا تمتلك سول اسلحه
نوويه ولا تستطيع مواجهه استفزازات جارتها
الشماليه
[موسيقى]
هذه الفكره تفتح الصفحات التاريخ الى
تاسيس الناتو في العام
1949 كانت هناك محاولات لاقامه تحالفات
امنيه اقليميه مشابهه في المنطقه لكنها لم
تنجح انذاك دول في اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
لمواجهه الخصوم الشيوعيين طبعا في دور
قياديا بامريكا ومنها الفلبين كوريا
الجنوبيه وحتى الصينيون القوميون بان
حربهم مع الشيوعيين الصينيين وكذلك
استراليا ونيوزيلندا ولكن بقيت وجهات
النظر حول كيفيه تحقيق ذلك مختلفه هل
النجاح سيكون حليفهم اليوم ويتمدد النيتو
في شرق اسيا ستمبر يرى ان ما يحدث في
اوروبا له عواقب على شرق اسيا وما يحدث
هناك مهم لاوروبا ولذلك يجب ان يكون هناك
تعاون اقوى ومن اجل ذلك وخلال قمه مدريد
في يونيو 2022 حدثت امورا تحدث لاول مره
كل من استراليا اليابان نيوزيلندا كوريا
الجنوبيه حضرت باول مره وفي وثيقه المفهوم
الاستراتيجي للحلف ذكرت الصين لاول مره
كما ذكرنا اعتبرنا الصين تحديا لمصالح دول
الحلف واميها والصين وكوريا الشماليه
تنتقدان هذه التصرفات طبعا اعتبرت بكين
تصريحات ستمبر عوده لعقليه الحرب البارده
اعتبرتها مقدمه للحرب فهل يقع المحظور
فعلا
لا يستبعد الجنرال مايك ميني هاند القائد
القائد قياده الحركه الجويه الامريكيه
خوضه حرب مع الصين في عام 2025 ويتفق معه
سياسيون عنده ومن بينهم رئيس لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه في مجلس النواب الامريكي مايك
ماكول
ايزكيشن
ماذا ان قامت الحرب فعلا عشرون سيناريو
قدمها مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه الدوليه
لكن السيناريو الاكثر احتمالا للحدود هو
بدايه الغزو بقصف صيني يدمر معظم البحريه
التايوانيه وقواتها الجويه ويفسح الطريق
لغزو برمائي
ستطوق تايوان وتمنع عنها اي محاولات
لايصال السفن والطائرات
وهنا ياتي دور واشنطن تسليح تايوان
بالكامل لكن قبل الحرب هذا الامر سيقلل من
تاثير الضربات الصينيه الاولى وسيجبر
الصينيين على الانتشار اكثر على طول
الساحل استخدام الولايات المتحده لقواعدها
في اليابان امر ضروري اخر مثل الوحده
البحريه التي تم تحديثها اخيرا والموجوده
في اوكيناوا تضم اكثر من 25 الف عسكريا
امريكي واكثر من 20 منشاه اختياره وتحديدا
جاء لانها قريبه من تايوان تبعد اقل من 70
ميلا من تايوان اذا السيناريو الصيني في
هذه الحاله سيكون حربا شاملا هجوم سريع
وعبور مضيق تايوان بغطاء جوي قصف صاروخي
وهجمات بالمقاتلات واللجوء للحرب
الالكترونيه بالطبع لكن ما نتيجه كل هذا
كارثه على الجميع اذا انتصر تحالف واشنطن
فلنصر سيكون مكلفا جدا على المدى الطويل
البحريه الامريكيه ستفقد حاملتي طائرات
على الاقل في المحيط الهادئ وهي اصلا
تمتلك احدى عشرات الخدمه وسيتدهور الجيش
التايواني بشده سيقتل 3200 جنديا في ثلاثه
اسابيع من القتال يعني تقريبا نصف ما
خسرته الولايات المتحده في عقدين من
القتال في العراق وافغانستان الكارثه ستحل
ايضا بالصين فبح
ستخسر اكثر من 130 سفينه كبيره ومئه وخمسه
وخمسين طائره مقاتله كما سيقتل حوالي عشره
الاف جندي وماذا عن تايوان شبه جزيره
مدمره بالكامل ومستقبل قاتل
[موسيقى]
ساعه قليله ويستيقظ غول اسعار جديد بازمه
جديده تاثيرها سريع ومباشر على حياتنا
حضروا المشتقات النفطيه المنقوله بحرا بعد
توجه نحو فرض سقف على اسعارها سيطلق
الفوضى وهي فوضى فبراير كما اسماها
الخبراء وببلوغ هذه النقطه فقدت رسميا
سوقا مدى جذور صادراتها من الطاقه فيها
طوال 50 عاما
على النفط والان المنتجات المكرره والغاز
قبلهما وهذا رسميا كان النفط الاسرع في
ايجاد منفذ بديل عن اوروبا وجهه مليونين
ونصف المليون برميل يوميا من خام موسكو
قبل الحرب الاوكرانيه فماذا عن المشتقات
منتجات اما بعد تكرير النفط الخام
كالسولار مثلا
طوي عمو 2022 على شحن
220 مليون برميل من الديزل الى الكتله
الاوروبيه من الموانئ الروسيه فهلا ستجد
طريقا اخر او ملاذا بعد اليوم وامن
المتضرر بهذه الحاله المصدر المستورد
بالنسبه لروسيا هناك تحد لكنه واعد لو
ابحرت المشتقات على خطى النفط الخام
بالاتجاه سيكون الى امريكا اللاتينيه
واسيا وافريقيا لكن للهند دور مفصلي النفط
الخام الروسي الذي بدا يتدفق اليها منذ
يونيو الماضي حل مكانا النفط العراقي في
سته اشهر
اقتنست نيودلهي غالبيه الشحنات بعد ان
قدمت موسكو خصومات خياليه وصلت الى 40% اي
ما يعادل 35 دولارا للبرميل والربح هنا
مزدوج فما تكرره الهند في مصافها تبيعه
باسعار مرتفعه لاوروبا ونتحدث عن كم
730 الف طن متريا شهريا منذ بدايه الحرب
هذه هي خديعه كبيره لكن الخديعه الكبرى
تتم في الولايات المتحده في نيويورك ومنذ
بدايه يصل يوميا تسعه وثمانون الف برميل
من البنزين والديزل الهندي هي اكبر كميه
خلال اربع سنوات تقريبا لكن يفسر ذلك
النقصان 28 مليون برميل عن متوسط السنوات
الخمس من نواتج التقطير الامريكيه بما
فيها الديزل والهند اسعفت الولايات
المتحده الكميه متوفره لديها بل والفائض
عنها بكثير ففي نفس الفتره اي منذ بدايه
يناير مليون و400 الف برميل نفط خام روسي
بلغ الاستيراد اليومي لي من الهند الى
الولايات المتحده وفقا لشركه كابلر ولا
يستثنى طبعا من كل هذه المعادله لا تستثنى
تركيا تستطيع هي الاخرى سد احتياجاتها من
الديزل الروسي تكرره وتبيعه بسعر السوق
لاوروبا
هذه التحويله بغض النظر عن نقطه الالتفاف
فيها تطرح تساؤلات حول جدوى العقوبات
روسيا تصرف منتجاتها بكل الاحوال وبخلاف
ذلك اسعار الطاقه في العالم سترتفع خبر
غير صار تنبا به بنك اوباما يقول ان مجرد
حظر المنتجات البتروليه الروسيه سيرفع
اسعار الديزل الى 200 دولار من سعره
المسجل في نهايه العام الماضي
128 دولار
اجراءات دول السبع على النفط والغاز
الروسيين ان شكلت ضربه موجعه للاقتصاد
الروسي تتمثل في خساره السواق ضخمه لصدره
روسيا من الطاقه بعد بدء سريان قرار موسكو
حول حظر تصدير نفطها مطلعا شهر الجاري
حولت روسيا منتجاتها البتروليه الى اسواق
بديله في السوق الاسيويه بما في ذلك عن
طريق البحر ولكن باسعار اقل من السوق
العالميه ابرز الدول التي تتصدر قائمه
مشتري الذهب الاسود الروسي هي الصين
والهند وتركيا وباكستان وبعض دول وسط اسيا
خطوه تاتي وسط صعوبات تقنيه من اجل اعاده
توجيه الصادرات خاصه مع الاضطرار الى
توسيع خط انابيب قوه سيبيريا الذي يصل
بالغاز الروسي الى الاراضي الصينيه
مرحله حساسه اذا يعيشها العالم وليست
روسيا وحدها غولوا التضخم استيقظ للتو
فسنعود الى المئه وعشرين مليون برميل من
الديزل التي استوردتها استوردها الاتحاد
الاوروبي من روسيا ماذا تمثل هذه الكميه
14 الف حوض سباحه اولمبي في هذه الكميات
استمراريه حياه على الاقل لاوروبا الديزل
الضروري للزراعه لا تحتمل المزيد من
التعقيدات بعد فصل جاف والديزل ايضا اساسي
للنقل البري الذي شحت عمليات الاستيراد من
خلاله لجلب مستلزمات الغذاء على مدى عام
كامل من الحرب ولان كل ما نستخدمه من
منتجات يتم شحنها في شاحنات او ناقلات
بالديزل فبالتالي الشحن البحري ايضا مهدد
وذلك بسبب ماده النفته التي تدخل في صناعه
البنزين والبلاستيك وزيت الوقود استهلك
ايضا في توليد الطاقه من كل هذه القطاعات
تستحوذ روسيا روسيا على اكثر من 9% لشحنات
المنتجات النفطيه العالميه
[موسيقى]
16 وسيله ضغط امريكيه على تركيا في الساعه
بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد رحله طويله قادتها موسكو
لتطبيع العلاقات بين تركيا والنظام السوري
ومع اقتراب المصالحه الكامله بين انقره
ودمشق تظهروا ملامح صفقات سياسيه حول
الملفات العالقه ومن بينهما دمشق اولا
تريد ان توقفوا توقف تركيا دعم المعارضه
السوريه عسكريا وسياسيا واقتصاديا ان
وافقت ان قرا على هذا الطلب للنظام سيكون
تدريجيا اما اولويه انقره فهي الحد من
النفوذ الكردي في شمال سوريا وتحديدا
التنظيمات التابعه لحزب العمال الكردستاني
كيف ان يقوم النظام السوري بحمايه الحدود
التركيه من تهديدات قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه التي تشكل وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكردي العمود الفقري لها قصاد من ناحيتها
لا تمانع هذا الخيار التركي بانتشار قوات
النظام لكن هناك مقابل تريده
الاعتراف الدستوري بقواتها وضمان مشاركتها
في العمليه السياسيه عمران ترفضهما تركيا
والنظام السوري تماما ما يضع قصد امام
خيارات محدوده
التواصلنا مستمر مع النظام السوري في
الملفات الامنيه والعسكريه لان الاقاليم
التي تنوي تركيا استهدافها يتواجد بها نحو
12 الف عنصر من قوات النظام السوري ويوجد
تنسيق بيننا طلبنا منهم التصدي لاي هجوم
تركي لكن النظام السوري لم يرد علينا حتى
الان بشان مواجهه الاحتلال التركي وهذا
واجبهم
رغم السيطره قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه على
نحو 25% من الجغرافيا السوريه ربع البلاد
كما هو ظاهر امامنا المناطق المغطاه
باللون الاصفر اجزاء واسعه من محافظه دير
الزور الرقه الحسكه وايضا اجزاء من محافظه
حلب الا ان الجغرافيا لا تدعم قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه فهي محاطه بقوات النظام
السوري جنوبا وشرقا نتحدث عن 63% من مساحه
البلاد وهذه المناطق الممثله بمحافظات
الساحل والوسط وايضا جنوب سوريا بالاضافه
الى اجزاء من المحافظات الشرقيه
كمحافظه حلب كذلك في المقابل تسيطر قوات
تركيا وقوات المعارضه المواليه لها على
اجزاء من الشريط الحدودي بين البلدين بين
تركيا وسوريا نتحدث عن نحو 10
من الجغرافيا السوريه تتوزع على ادلب
وايضا الشمال حلب وفي منطقه تل ابيض وراس
العين في الرقه وايضا في الحسكه وفي منطقه
الزكاه والتنف هذه الجغرافيا تقلص خيارات
قصد اذا في حال رفضهم الامتثال للشروط
التركيه وعلى راسها الانسحاب لمسافه 30
كيلومترا عن حدود تركيا الجنوبيه وهذا
الرفض يضع قصاد امام عمليه عسكريه تركيه
طاله التلويح بها وسيوافق عليها النظام
السوري وروسيا لكن هناك خيار امام قصد
الاعتماد على دعم واشنطن لها والاخيره
ترفض العمليه التركيه المحتمله وتحاول
عرقله التعاون التركي الروسي وسائل الضغط
كثيره ورقه الاف 16
حاضره
نعمل مع الامريكيين على الارض ويعلمون ان
قيادات قصد سوريون ولدينا واجب نحو سوريا
واوضح ذلك بشكل رسمي على قناتكم بانه لا
علاقه تنظيميه رسميه او صله لنا مع حزب
العمال الكردستاني ولسنا فرعا منه نحن
نمارس اعمالنا كمنظمه سياسيه سوريه ودعيني
اضيف شيئا اخر هناك عدد كبير من مقاتلي
حزب العمال الكردستاني شاركوا معنا في
القتال ضد داعش ونحو اربعه الاف عنصر منهم
قتلوا هنا وادوا واجبهم القومي الكردي قسم
كبير منهم عاد وقسم اخر بقي عالقا هنا
لديها وسائل للضغط اذن لكنها تحاول
الاستفاده تريد واشنطن ضمانه وجود عسكريا
ومستقر لها في سوريا ورغم تخليصي عدد
القوات الى 900 عسكري لكن هناك ضغط
الاعلام الامريكيه تساءل عن مدى جدوى
الوجود في سوريا وسيله الولايات المتحده
في الضمان وجودها هو اقامه مشروع جديد في
مناطق شمال شرق سوريا لكن ذلك سيفقد قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه المتحالفه مع جزءا من
نفوذها فيها واشنطن تعتزم بناء تحالف جديد
بين الجناح السياسي لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه واطراف اخرى من المعارضه بما
يشمل زياده نسبه المكون العربي في
المؤسسات السياسيه والعسكريه شمال شرقي
سوريا وفي هذا الاطار تطالب واشنطن قصد
بفك ارتباطها نهائيا بحزب العمال
الكردستاني قصد اكدت اخيرا ان لا علاقه
لها بالحزب والمصنط كارها انقره و واشنطن
لكن رغم كل ذلك تمتلك قصد ورقه حاسمه
ومنطقيه امام جميع الاطراف الخصوم
والشركاء ولوحت بها اي عمليه عسكريه تركيه
ستحول دون استمرارنا في استهداف عناصر
داعش وحتى قدرتنا على حراسه معسكرات
اعتقالهم
اذن تقليص او انهاء للنفذ الكردي شمال شرق
سوريا يفيد دوله اخرى الوسيط روسيا موسكو
ستتخلص من حليف واشنطن في سوريا وايضا
ستنجح في زياده رقعه الاراضي الواقعه تحت
سياده النظام السوري حليفها لكن هناك لاعب
محوري في الازمه السوريه لم تشمله
التغيرات الجيوسيه الجديده ايران عالميا
لم تخفي طهران انزعاجها من التقارب السوري
التركي دون ضوء اخضر منها وانزعاج انعكس
في قرار الحد من تزويد دمشق بالوقود
باسعار مخفضه موقفه طهران يزداد وضوحا مع
تحركاتها الدبلوماسيه زيارتان مفاجئتان
لدمشق وانقره قام بهما وزير الخارجيه
الايرانيه حسين امير عبداللهيان في الرابع
عشر والسابع عشر من يناير الماضي على
التوالي التي اعاقبتها تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه النظام السوري من طهران بان
التقارب مع انقره يجب ان على اسس انهاء ما
قال انه احتلال ومكافحه ارهاب
المصالح هي اساس والتقارب هكذا يفهم مساره
التطبيع بين تركيا والنظام السوري انقره
التي تسارع الخطى على هذا الطريق تهدف الى
اعاده ثلاثه ملايين الف لاجئ سوري على
اراضيها الى بلادهم ايضا استئناف العلاقات
التجاريه وفتح المعابر المغلقه بين
البلدين منذ اكثر من عقد لكن الهدف
الاساسي هو القضاء على الحلم الكردي
المتشكل في الشمال الشرقي تحت السلطه
العسكريه لقوات قصد هدف تتناغم فيه موسكو
مع انقره قد يعيد النظام الى الشمال
الشرقي الغني بالنفط والموارد المائيه
والزراعيه لكن هناك سد امريكي الطريق
معقده والمفاوضات ليست سهله فما يفرق
الخصمين اكثر مما يجمعهما مثالا الاسد
استخدم الكيماوي في دوما انقره تدين وترفض
بينما دمشق تنفي صراع المواقف واختلافاتها
قد يطيح بالفرص التي اتاحها اللقاء الاخير
في موسكو بين الطرفين
من اربيل ينضم الينا استاذ الفلسفه
السياسيه في جامعه كويا دكتوره سيرفستنا
نبي من اسطنبول ايضا المحلل السياسي
التركي
سابدا معك اذا بتعرف تركيا ماذا يريد
النظام بالضبط وايضا تسر انقره وتقول ان
المحادثات الثلاثيه متواصله
فهل ستقدم تركيا التنازلات او هل ستقدم ما
يريده النظام السوري منها
تحيه طيبه
اولا ما
ظهر معنى ظهر على الشاشه باسم مظلوم ابتي
والشخص مطلوب للعضاله في تركيا على خلفيه
قضايا ارهابيه وهو يتزعم الاصابات
الارهابيه في سوريا
لو تجيب على سؤالي رجاء رجاء
التاكيدات من قبل انقره بمواصله المحادثات
والتقارب مع دمشق هل هذا يعني الان انا
هناك من جهه انقره قبول ابي الشروط لدمشق
للنظام السوري على الاقل بالانسحاب من
الشمال
بالنسبه الحوار مع الحكومه السوريه نحن ما
زلنا في بدايه
الحوار والتواصل
قد
يتحول يتطور هذا الحبار والتواصل الى
تقارب والتفاهمات ولكن اذا اشترط النظام
شروطا استعراضيه لا يمكن طبعا هذه قبول
هذه الموافقه على هذه الشروط مثل الانسحاب
قبل اي التسويه السياسيه في سوريا او طعم
او قطع الطعم من المعارضه السوريه قبل
التسويه النهائيه وهذه الشروط غير مقبوله
تركيا تريد من النظام السوري
مواجهه
الفصائل الارهابيه
الانفصاليه بدلا من الشعب السوري وكذلك
تبحث امكانيه
التعاون في في مساله اعاده اللاجئين
وتامين الحدود المشتركه في حاله تلبيه
النظام لهذه الشروط تركيا
جاهزه
لمواصله هذا الحوار وهذه
التواصل نعم انتقل الى الدكتور ساره
بستطور الى التقارب نعم ما هذا التطور
انتقل الى الدكتور سربست نبي اذا دكتور ما
هي الاوراق الان لدى قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه والاكراد في سوريا اذا كانت
تركيا رغم رغم هذا التقارب ايضا تتحدث
الان التقارير عن تثبيت وجودها اكثر بعشره
الاف جندي في الشمال عشرات القواعد ما هي
الورقه هل قوه ورقه داعش تكفي
مساء الخير
عمليه
المساومات والمقايضات بين النظامين لم
تنقطع
وبدات تتكثف بصوره اساسيه منذ 2016
حيث كانت المعارضه السوريه تسيطر على اكثر
من 75
والنظام لم يكن يسيطر الا على 17% من
مجموع مساحه سوريا الا ان الفوبيا الكرديه
التي تعصف بالراس السياسي تعصف بذهنيه
التركيه هي التي دفعت الرئيس التركي الى
والحكومه التركيه الى التنازل عن الخطوط
الحمر من ادعاء الصلاه بضروره الصلاه
في مسجد الاموي الى خطوط الحمر في حمص وفي
حلب قيد التضحيه كل السوريين دماء كل
السوريين لاجل الهدف وحيد هو الكابوس الذي
يخيم على ذلك كابوس القضيه
ودعمت الجماعات الارهابيه دعم الداعش دمع
دعمت فصائل متطرفه تحمل لواء الجهاديه
دعمت القاعده دعمت كل عمل ومجموعه ارابيه
في هذا العام فتحت مطار عنتاب كان البوابه
الكبرى لجحيم الارهابي في هذا العالم في
وقت من الاوقات القصد استطعت وحدات حمايه
الشعب الكردي وقصد الصمود في مواجهه كل
هذه التحديات وفي مواجهه كل الغزوات وفي
مواجهه كل المجاميع الارهاب حتى باتت
المناطق الارهابيه
لا تقاطعني لا تقاطعني خليني اكمل
خليني اكمل لا تقاطعني انت تفطر على على
يكمل رجاء
انت تضاف يا انت تربط الاكراد بالتنظيم
الارهابي وتضاف يعني الارهابي يلمز
انتم لا ليس عندكم غير الشتائم والصراخ
انت انت مثل الذي يدعس على ذنبه اسكت
خليني نعم نعم
هذا الرجل
يتحدث عن خطوط حمص
لو سمحتوا لي رجاء خليني اكمل لو سمحتي
ساعود اليك دكتور لكن الان قصد
اسمحي لي بس قست تملك الاوراق واقتنع
المجتمع الدولي حتى الان بضروره بقاء ودعم
لان غياب قست في هذه الاوقات يعني انفلات
المنطقه امنيا وعوده داعش مجددا للهيمنه
على كل شمال السوري وهذا ما تريد تركيا
هجوم الاخير على سجن غويران اثبت ان
الاسلحه التي استخدمها الدواعش في الهجوم
كانت بحوزه الميليشيات التابعه لتركيا ما
يسمى بالجيش الوطني في المناطق التي تحت
سيطرت
ساعه سيطره القوات التركيه هذا الكلام ليس
من طرفي مؤسسات محايده مؤسسات اعلاميه
دوليه بريطانيه واوروبيه نشرت بالارقام
والرموز الخاصه بهذه الاسلحه كيف وصلت الى
يد الدواعش لهذا السبب الولايات المتحده
في الاونه الاخيره وجهت رسائل صارمه الى
الحكومه التركيه بضروره التوقف عن هذه
المشاحنات عن هذا هذه الممارسات الارهابيه
في شمال شرق سوريا والكف عن فعل ذلك
للاسف داهمنا الوقت انتهى وقت المقابله
اشكركم جزيلا من اربيل استاذ الفلسفه
السياسيه في جامعه كويا الدكتور بس نبي
ومن اسطنبول المحلل السياسي التركي
اوكتاريا
[موسيقى]
في نهايه الساعه الحرب الاوكرانيه اثارها
السلبيه كثيره على الحياه على كوكب الارض
وعلى الحياه خارجيه ايضا من الان وحتى
الساعه المقبله انا حنين وهذه الساعه سته
[موسيقى]